[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei den damen und
herren zu einer sondersendung von vielen
nach acht werden heute aber
monothematisch über den ukraine krieg
sprechen wie wahrscheinlich ist eine
diplomatische lösung wie wirksam sind
die deutschen sanktionen
waffenlieferungen und könnte deutschland
in den krieg mit hineingezogen werden
meine gäste linke politikerin und
publizistin sahra wagenknecht sie
schreckt nie davor zurück eine andere
meinung zu vertreten heute erst warnte
sie im bundestag vor den deutschen
sanktionen herr scholz merken sie nicht
dass die ganze sanktionspolitik uns mehr
als putin schadet schön dass sie da sind
frau wagenknecht hat sie bekommen auch
im pforzheimer hier im studio kein
reporter war so lange im ukraine krieg
und so dicht dran die er paulis der
einzige deutsche journalisten
ukrainische präsident selensky während
des krieges mehrfach getroffen hat ich
freue mich sehr dass du sicher und
wohlbehalten nach drei monaten zurück
bist hier im studio und zugeschaltet ist
uns aus wien oberst ag wolfgang richter
seine forschungsgebiete russland
osteuropa sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik und völkerrecht im
februar veröffentlichte er die
wissenschaftliche arbeit ukraine im nato
russland spannungsfeld herzlich
willkommen auch an sie herr richter
lassen sie uns nun direkt beginnt paul
die erste frage geht ein dichtes jetzt
drei monate in der ukraine
was ist das erlebnis was die am meist so
das einschneidendste erlebnis was du
dort erlebt hast für mich ganz
persönlich sicherlich der tod eines
journalisten kollegen von fox news
ein kollege mit dem ich im gleichen
hotel gewohnt habe und wir uns morgens
immer beim frühstück getroffen haben und
über sicherheit gesprochen haben und an
dem morgen hat er mir erzählt wie er in
richtung er hin wollte das war damals
der umkämpfte ort und da kann man am
abend nicht mehr wieder von einer rakete
das team getroffen hat auch eine
ukrainische kollegin ist gestorben und
krieg wird ja für einen persönlich immer
dann anfassbar und
besonders schlimm wenn man
freunde verliert
und wenn ich mich da rein versetzte und
sehe wie viele menschen mittlerweile in
der ukraine jemanden kennen niemanden
verloren haben der ganz nahe stand da
wird das kann so drama dieses krieges
deutlich er war ja auch nicht der
einzige journalist der sein leben
gelassen hat in den letzten monaten der
ukraine gewöhnt man sich denn selbst ein
krieg als kriegsreporter wie du an die
gefahr vor ort
ja das ist immer eine gefahr dass man zu
weit geht dass man
zu lange an der frontlinie zum beispiel
bleibt aber
so richtig gewöhnen eine richtige
gewöhnung setzt eigentlich nicht ein
weil es immer eine neue gefahrenlage
gibt eine neue situationen gibt aber ich
muss sagen nach drei monaten habe ich
gemerkt durchaus wie ein dass psychisch
fertig macht das natürlich nichts im
vergleich zu dem was was andere dort
erlebt haben aber an dass man träume hat
dass man träumt dass russen so russische
soldaten den ort ein kessel in dem man
sich befindet und eine situation habe
ich besonders vor augen ich bin davon
aufgewacht wie ich mich wehren wollte
ich habe ein airport im ohr gehabt und
mit diesem dann gegen die wand geworfen
habe davon bin ich aufgewacht im traum
also sind schon so momente ja die dann
natürlich auch die journalisten
psychisch belasten und es waren auch
moment die du ja mit dem präsidenten mit
polonaise lenski erlebt hast du hast ihn
mehrfach interviewt welchen eindruck hat
er auf dich gemacht für viele ist er ein
held andere sagen aber auch er
inszeniert sich sehr stark er der auf
dich gewirkt paul ja das war ein
interview märz dass wir mit ihm geführt
haben wir zwei interviews geführt 1 noch
im april das war nicht mehr der gleiche
seelands gea der märz das war der see
lenski der angst hatte dass die stadt
eingekesselt werden könnte ja das war
ein interview zwischen barrikaden so
ungefähr zwischen sandsäcken und ich
glaube der präsident hat es perfekt
verstanden aus seiner sicht zu
kommunizieren und hat damit sozusagen
auch das bild der ukraine geprägt und
ich glaube es ist der erste krieg wo wir
so unmittelbar durch soziale medien
dabei sein können und nehmen nicht nur
journalisten die dort sind wie ich die
interviews führen sondern der präsident
eben ganz oft selbst und dadurch hat er
sich
insbesondere in der ukraine schon zu
einer ikone entwickelt und ich glaube
die tatsache dass er ebenso viel druck
gemacht hat hat auch am ende dazu
geführt dass waffenlieferungen zum
beispiel passiert frau wagenknecht sie
verfolgen ja auch den krieg sehr genau
welche rolle hat für sie lenski bislang
gespielt und ist es inszenierung oder
machte einen guten job gut er ist
präsident eines überfallenen landes und
natürlich nutzt er alle möglichkeiten in
der öffentlichkeit auch gerade eben in
westlichen ländern dafür zu werben dass
ein land unterstützt wird das ist ja
sein das ist ja seinen job das ist auch
nachvollziehbar trotzdem finde ich
müssen wir immer wieder und auch bei
allen bewusst sein das ist wichtig ist
die ukraine zu unterstützen wir vor
allem auch humanitär auch diplomatisch
zu unterstützen natürlich schon sehen
die ukraine hat auch interessen die
nicht unsere interessen sind also
ukrainisches interesse ist es natürlich
die nato immer mehr in den krieg zu
ziehen weil das ja ihre chance erheblich
erhöht diesen krieg zu gewinnen aber das
kann nicht unser interesse sein weil das
ist natürlich für uns eine wahnsinnig
gefährliche strategie und deswegen
glaube ich muss man da auch immer noch
unterscheiden so wie gesagt er macht das
für sein land und das ist ja auch völlig
legitim und völlig okay aber trotzdem
haben wir hier auch noch
unterschiedliche interessen und ich muss
sagen ich finde schon bedauerlich also
ich habe wahrgenommen dass er zum
beispiel in istanbul als da in
verhandlungen ja am laufen waren da gab
es ja einen verstoß von ukrainischer
seite bestimmte kompromisse zu machen
und wenn man das durchgehalten hätte
hätte man den krieg vielleicht schon
beenden können ich weiß es nicht aber
diese wunder wieder zurückgenommen und
aktuell gibt es ja faktisch gar keinen
keine grundlage für verhandlungen
und ehrlich gesagt ist mir die strategie
nicht klar also zu sagen wir wollen
jetzt russland militärisch besiegen als
ukraine russland ist eine atommacht und
das russland sozusagen sich komplett
geschlagen gibt komplett die ukraine
verlässt ohne alle militärischen karten
ausgereizt zu haben das sehe ich nicht
und deswegen glaube ich kann der krieg
nur durch ein kompromiss beendet werden
der kompromiss darf nicht sein dass die
ukraine ein russisches predrag
protektorat wird das ist ja kein
kompromiss das wäre ja eine unterwerfung
aber es wird meines erachtens auch nicht
darauf hinauslaufen dass russland
irgendwann sagt okay wir gehen jetzt
hier raus wir räumen alles und ihr habt
den krieg gewonnen weil was da vorher
passieren würde das wäre so schrecklich
dass man das meines erachtens nicht
riskieren darf aber fangen wir haben
doch schon erlebt dass es funktionieren
kann dass russische truppen sich
zurückziehen nämlich in kiew das
ursprüngliche ziel von wladimir putin
war die hauptstadt einzunehmen und durch
militärische stärke durch westliche
waffen durch kluge militär strategie in
kiew hat man es geschafft dass die
russischen soldaten nicht in die
hauptstadt gekommen sind jetzt geht es
um den osten und auch da ich war letzte
woche noch vor ort im donbass sagen mir
dort die militärs und auch die soldaten
dass sie imstande sind sich dort zu
verteidigen und dass sie sich auch
imstande führen bestimmte besetzte
gebiete zurückzuerobern im tonnen was
und da ist doch die klare frage wenn sie
sagen die ukraine hätten einen
kompromiss nicht möglich gemacht die
tatsache ist doch dass wladimir putin
sich dagegen sperrt mit überhaupt zu
sprechen es gab ja verhandlungen also
nicht zwischen putin und seelands gehe
aber zwischen russischer seite und
ukrainischer seite das war ja ein ganz
wichtiger weg und man hat ja dort so ein
korridor ausgehandelt und sie haben ja
in einem punkt recht ich glaube schon
dass die russische führung am anfang ein
ganz anderes andere vorstellungen davon
hatte wie dieser krieg laufen wird also
offensichtlich warten sie die
vorstellung wir gehen da rein und nach
sechs tagen sind wenn kiew diese
vorstellung ist gescheitert also das war
ist komplett war eine völlige verkennung
der realität sie haben dann ihre
positionen umgruppiert aber es ist ja
nicht so dass sie jetzt ich meine sie
haben ja schon langsam aber doch eben
mühsam es die südflanke erheblich
besetzt sie haben don was einiges
besetzt und sie werden dort nicht
einfach so mal wieder abziehen sie haben
ja noch ein immenses waffen potenzial
sie haben enorme ressourcen
sie haben auch noch viel schlimmere
waffen als bisher eingesetzt wurden und
bevor sie dort abziehen werden sie
sicherlich das was sie militärisch
können auch zum einsatz bringen und die
frage ist wollen wir das und was
passiert vor allem wenn das immer mehr
eskaliert also wenn immer mehr waffen
dann auch der nato eingesetzt werden
wird auch putin brutalere waffen
einsetzen und sie haben ja vorhin zu
recht gesagt und das ist ja auch
geschildert der kollege der gestorben
ist ich meine jeden tag sterben frauen
sterben kinder wenn man eine möglichkeit
hätte mit einem kompromiss diesen krieg
zu beenden
wie viele tausende hunderttausende
menschen leben würde das retten und ich
persönlich kenne auch mir schreiben
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer die zum
beispiel jetzt in deutschland sind die
haben mir geschrieben dass sie wirklich
alles sich sehnlichst wünschen dass der
krieg endet weil ihre männer sind dort
die können auch nicht raus und sie haben
eine wahnsinnige angst dass sie
irgendwann eingezogen werden kämpfen
müssen und fallen und das sind dann
junge männer familienväter das ist doch
schrecklich das muss man doch beenden
hier würde ich gerne einmal herrn
richter reinholen und ihn um seine
militärische expertise bitten herr
richter ist es denn möglich für die
ukraine den krieg gegen russland zu
gewinnen
ja geschenkt und auch angst ausrichtung
von uns heimat
ich glaube wir sollten vorsichtig sein
mit dem begriff sieg und gewinnen also
aus ukrainischer sicht gewinnt man einen
krieg wenn man sich erfolgreich
verteidigen kann es ist völlig unklar
was die kriegsziele im moment sind
sowohl von russischer seite aus aber
auch von ukrainischer seite denn die
kompromiss formulierungen die wir gehört
haben der ende märz vom präsident
selensky die kann man ja schnell
erklären das ist nicht beitritt senator
das sind kompromisse oder gespräche über
die über einen territorien sonderstatus
dass die creme angeht um den dom bass
und sicherheitsgarantien für die ukraine
sehen auf der russischen seite
allerdings zwei unterschiedliche
negative es ist völlig unklar was jetzt
dort dominiert traditionell reden wir
über russische sicherheitsinteressen die
haben was zu tun wird im heranrücken der
nato mit die russischen grenzen um mit
potentiellen stationierung sven kürzeren
flugzeiten
etc
das sind die traditionelle dinge die
auch sich nur widergespiegelt haben in
den entwürfen vom dezember
über die wir also in der vergangenheit
über rüstungskontrolle abkommen et
cetera verhandelt haben wir sehen aber
ein neues narrativ ukrainischer
identität neu
gestellt ob es überhaupt eine
berechtigung für einen ukrainischen
staat gibt man mit metaphern arbeitet
wie den artifiziellen
und demilitarisierung etc es ist also
völlig unklar was eigentlich das
kriegsziel von der seite sein soll
unklar ist allerdings auch was ein
kriegsziel sein soll dass eine nicht
kriegsführenden partei formuliert die
darauf aus geht also die russischen
streitkräfte zu ruinieren und so zu
verknüpfen dass sie nicht mehr in der
lage sind über lange sicht überhaupt
eine größere operation zu führen beides
halte ich für keine gute
verhandlungsgrundlage
und hier das wäre auch meine antwort an
sahra wagenknecht wenn es derzeit keine
wirkliche verhandlungsgrundlage gibt und
ich befürchte dass die ukraine während
auch etwas zurück und von den kompromiss
formulierung
dann haben wir natürlich schlechte
aussichten den krieg zu beenden aber zum
verhandeln gehören immer zwei und damit
zur militärischen lage die in kiew hat
sich gezeigt in der phase eins dass die
operationen auf einer völligen
fehleinschätzung der obersten
militärischen und politischen führung
russlands beruht nämlich genau auf
diesem relativ dass es ohnehin keinen
nationalen widerstandswillen geben würde
und dass viele ukraine mit blumen denn
befreiung vom faschismus also entgegen
ein würden und das aber war fürchterlich
der ukrainische widerstandswillen ist
natürlich in den letzten acht jahren
gewachsen man kann das nicht mehr
vergleichen mit der situation von 2014
lokale der armee keine lust hatten zu
kämpfen und andere sogar übergelaufen
sind insbesondere die schwarzmeerflotte
teile die ukrainischen teile der
schwarzmeerflotte auf der krim das hat
sich total geändert wir haben eine
homogene
nationen die streitkräfte sind
geschlossen sind gut ausgebildeten auch
gut ausgerüstet sie waren immer schon
ein starker arm es war nur die
motivation frage ich klicke jahr 2014
und dass dieser fehler der einschätzung
hat sich dann natürlich über die
militärischen hierarchien hinunter
multipliziert errichten logistischer
brechen dürfte die frage lohnt sich
natürlich stellt ist selbstverständlich
ist es sehr differenziert aber als
bürgerin wie ich frage ich mich schon
ist es denn zu lösen also sollte
deutschland jetzt schwere waffen
weiterhin liefern oder noch mehr liefern
also da muss man ja schon fragen ob die
ukraine überhaupt singen kann oder ist
die frage wirklich so falsch gestellt
also ich glaube man kann es nur erklären
wenn man den ablauf der operation sieht
die chance eins ist gescheitert ich
erspare mir details in der phase 2 in
dem wir uns jetzt befinden haben die
russen versucht ihre fehler der phase 1
auszumerzen sie bilden jetzt einen
klaren schwerpunkt auf den don was sie
haben einen einheitlichen oberbefehl
hergestellt ihre strukturen dieser
panzer und artillerie stark sind sind
besser geeignet für ein offenes flaches
gelände mit weniger geld wirkungen und
da gehen sie also jetzt auch vor und
wenn sie nicht wieder den fehler machen
sich zu verbeißen in stadt kämpfen wo
man viel infanterie hat was die russen
nicht haben dann haben sie die chance
etwas geländegewinne zu machen derzeit
sehen wir allerdings dass das nur sehr
langsam voran geht und gleichzeitig
inhalten zurückgenommen werden oder die
ukraine eben auch geländegewinne machen
das heißt diese sogenannte schlacht in
bonn was ist noch lange nicht gelaufen
und das wird wahrscheinlich darauf
hinauslaufen dass es auf die ressourcen
ankommt die beide seiten mobilisieren
können die ukraine vertrauen darauf dass
der waffen strom aus dem westen anhält
und russland hat noch nicht alles
mobilisiert viele haben erwartet am
neunten weiters putin die
generalmobilmachung verkünden würde es
nicht getan das heißt ja nicht dass sie
vom tisch ist das heißt wir wollen jetzt
überzogene kriegsziele formuliert weil
da wirklich mal dran erinnern dass die
krim mittlerweile aus russischer sicht
nicht aus unsere aber aus russischer
sicht staatsterritorium ist dann geht
man natürlich an die substanz des
russischen sicherheitsinteressen
bevor überhaupt die schlacht im don pass
geschlagen ist und jetzt kann man
natürlich sagen ja wenn es auf eine
abnutzung einen abnutzungskrieg hin
läuft dann wird alles noch länger und
auch noch fürchterlicher aber es muss
einfach klar sein dass bei verhandlungen
die verhandlungsposition der ukraine so
stabil ist dass es eben nicht in einen
unterwerfung frieden übergeht und dass
man wirklich die möglichkeit hat einen
kompromiss frieden zu schließen mit
ihren element ist das ja schon vor
meiner sicht ja das würde ich gerne
einmal in die runde geben zur diskussion
das stichwort unter wärme gerade genannt
haben hier gebe ich gerne stichwort
einmal an paul ronzheimer rüber wäre ein
frieden denn ein unterwerfung frieden es
kommt drauf an wie so ein kompromiss
aussehen also ich glaube auch dass ab
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt ist natürlich
verhandlung geben wird und das ist eine
hoch schwierige und auch hoch emotionale
frage für das ganze land denn man muss
sich das so vorstellen
ich würde dem widersprechen was frau
wagenknecht gesagt hat oder ich habe
zumindest in den eindruck den sie
vermittelt haben dass die meisten
ukrainer sagen sie wollen dass der krieg
sofort auf natürlich nicht um jeden
preis aber das ist natürlich mein leben
natürlich die menschen dass der krieg
aufhört nur es gibt eine weitere
komponente es sind mittlerweile so viele
menschen gestorben
es sind so viele orte
total zerstört worden dass die stimmung
die ich dort in der ukraine wahrnehme so
ist dass man sagt wir werden nicht
aufgeben ich hatte damals erwartet zu
beginn des krieges dass die moral
sich eher nach unten entwickeln würde
also dass die ukrainische soldaten aber
auch in der ukrainischen bevölkerung ab
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
man sagt wir können das nicht dauerhaft
gewinnen aber das gegenteil ist der fall
also die ukraine ist entschlossen und
sie wird weiter im land verteidigen ganz
egal auch was die westlichen staaten
machen ob sie jetzt viele waffen oder
weniger öffentlich ich glaube dass die
ukraine irland selbst verteidigt ich
glaube da haben auch sie nichts dagegen
frau wagenknecht das ist ja logisch also
ich meine natürlich wollen nach meinem
empfinden also sie waren dort aber ich
zumindest was ich hier als gesprächen
entnommen haben natürlich wollen die
übergroße mehr der ukrainerin und
ukraine jetzt nicht unter russischer
oberherrschaft leben und ich glaube das
wäre ja auch dann tatsächlich eine
unterwerfung frieden aber ein kompromiss
wäre ja das was man eben zum beispiel
ist dann wohl so in den groben linien
schon mal ausgehandelt hatte also
neutralität gegen sicherheitsgarantien
verzicht auf die perspektive an der nato
mitgliedschaft und eben spezieller
status don was und krim und wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel also ich bin auch
kein kreml astrologen ich weiß nicht was
in putins kopf vorgeht aber ich höre ja
das was er sagt und ich sehe einen
großen unterschied zwischen seiner rede
direkt am anfang des krieges die
tatsächlich diesen brutalen
nationalismus enthielt wo er gesagt hat
als die ukraine hat gar kein
existenzrecht und dem was er zum
beispiel jetzt am 9 mai gesagt hat das
war sehr defensiv und meines erachtens
wäre die russische führung also wenn sie
irgendwie rational ist und ich glaube
das ist sie schon noch dass sie
möglichst ich denke dass er froh so ist
wenn er jetzt einen gesichtswahrenden
ausweg hat also weil der krieg ja eben
nicht so gelaufen ist wie sie das
gedacht haben ob es von vornherein jetzt
wirklich um eine solche unterwerfung
überhaupt gegen weiß ich nicht ich meine
man muss natürlich auch sehen krieg
führende politiker sagen selten worum es
in dem krieg wirklich geht also als die
usa in den usa im irak eingefallen ist
haben sie auch nicht gesagt es geht ums
öl sondern sie haben gesagt es geht um
massenvernichtungswaffen die wir
vernichten wollen obwohl sie gar nicht
gab und ich würde dienst damalige rede
wo er also wirklich in villa weise
gesagt hat die ukraine hat überhaupt
kein existenzrecht ich glaube das war
auch ans eigene volk er musste ja
irgendwie versuchen die menschen
mitzunehmen aber ob das jetzt wirklich
das kriegsziel war weiß ich nicht
zumindest glaub ich ist es jetzt nicht
mehr das kriegs iva ist völlig
unrealistisch wäre völlig unrealistisch
und aber was realistisch wäre wäre eben
ein solcher verhandlung skurrile und
meines wissens das war in der presse
also die washington post hat das
geschrieben auch der guardian ist das
gescheitert dieses verhandlungs diese
verhandlungsoptionen nicht daran dass
die russen nein gesagt haben sondern
dass die ukraine sich von dieser von
diesem zugeständnis bezogen auf einen
verzicht auf die nato-mitgliedschaft
wieder zurückgezogen haben nachdem
öffentlich zum beispiel boris johnson ja
seelands gerüffelt hat ja gesagt was
macht ihr hier für kompromisse findet er
nicht gut und aus amerikanischer seite
kamen auch ziemlich kritiken und dann
muss man jetzt sehen da sind wieder ganz
spezielle interessen der beiden will
seine wahlen gewinnen im november da
muss er jetzt sozusagen irgendwie als
als kriegsheld dastehen und nicht als
soll mann der da einen kompromiss das
sind aber alles dinge die eigentlich
keine rolle spielen dürfen wenn es darum
geht diesen furchtbaren krieg zu beenden
wenn sie jetzt damit anfangen sozusagen
die usa verantwortlich dafür zu machen
und zu sagen
dass am ende druck gemacht das ist am
ende sozusagen darum gehe dass es dort
in politische kämpfe zu gewinnen gibt
also das halte ich für ziemlich grossen
blödsinn muss ich sagen denn wenn wir
uns anschauen wie joe biden zu beginn
des krieges und davor ja alles versucht
hat auch mit putin zu sprechen es gab ja
diese gespräche olaf scholz ist nach
moskau gereist alle haben es ja versucht
vor dem krieg also vor dem 24 februar
und wenn wir uns die situation dort bei
den verhandlungen anschauen dann muss
man ja sagen dass wladimir putin so
hatte sich zumindest gezeigt zu keinem
zeitpunkt ein interesse hatte als es
noch um minister burg gegen dort einen
frieden zu erlangen weil die hatten doch
die hatten meines wissens ein dokument
über einen waffenstillstand wo dann
zumindest die russische seite sich
beschwert hat dass die ukraine von
dingen die sich schon zugesagt hatten
sich wieder zurückgenommen haben zum
beispiel eben diese und südlichen leute
nein ich glaube aber zum beispiel ein
bericht der washington post am 5 april
die genau das gleiche berichtet hat die
nur eben dazu noch gesagt hat dass es da
einflussnahmen gab von der nato auf die
lenski dass er diese kompromisse nicht
machen soll so und wenn ich jetzt können
sie natürlich auch sagen die washington
post ist auf und protein gesteuert
glaube ich nicht also ich merke also man
merkt doch es gab doch ein
strategiewechsel im westen also ich
glaube das können sie doch auch nicht
bestreiten es gab nach diesem treffen in
ramstein wo sie sie alle zusammen
gesetzt hat einen deutlichen der rallye
die wechsel mann hatte zunächst das
gefühl auch die europäer zumindest haben
doch eher druck gemacht einen schnellen
frieden einen kompromiss zu finden
und ab da wurde ganz klar in der
kommunikation auf einen langen krieg
orientiert es wurde gesagt wir liefern
jetzt ganz viel waffen und als
kriegsziel wurde ausgegeben wir müssen
russland in die knie zwingen wir müssen
russland maximal schwächen aber ehrlich
gesagt es muss doch darum gehen den
krieg sowohl das vokabular in die knie
zwang
aber das war ja aber das ist ja
sozusagen ein vokabular
es ist aber nicht von mir so so machen
sie aber so wie sie sprechen sozusagen
putin zum opfer der arme putin muss ja
auch gesagt schwierigen lage
herauskommen der arme präsident dass er
zumindest ein bisschen von der ukraine
bekommt weil eigentlich kiew bekommen
hat und deswegen soll er jetzt irgendwie
teile des ostens bekommen also das halte
ich für höchst problematisch dass wir
immer noch in dieser weise über wladimir
putin diskutieren und wir müssen ja
einmal zurückgehen an dem beginn des
krieges wo
sicherheitsexperten militärberater die
gesamte westliche welt eigentlich gesagt
hat weil man gedacht hatte dass die
russische armee so stark ist dass man
eben innerhalb von wenigen tagen in kiew
ist so als die ukraine sich so
heldenhaft verteidigt habe und es klar
war dass diese armee sehr wohl eine
chance hat in der ukraine und das ist
nicht funktioniert da eine chance sein
naja ihr land zu verteidigen ja aber
doch nicht da also dazu den krieg
militärisch für sich zu entscheiden das
ist doch eine illusion dass sein sohn
noch einmal kiew wo er redet über eine
atommacht die ihn ja in zweifel
1911 nach dem anderen sie sagen immer
man kann diesen krieg nicht militärisch
lösen noch einmal in kiew wurde die
russische armee zurückgedrängt wurde ist
der moment da wurde das wurde da gab es
eine militärische lösung und mainhausen
schlaffheit sie haben sich um kopien sei
sicher sind weiß ich das verdaut habe
weil sie sind verrechnen sie haben sich
also mächtig sind sie sind abgezogen
weil sie sich dann eben
bayerische lösung also wir sehen jeden
tag aber das war keine situation wo die
russen alles mobilisiert haben was sie
an militärischen kapazitäten haben
sondern sie haben sich dann weil ihr
konzept nicht aufgegangen ist das stimmt
sie hatten eine andere vorstellung was
sie dort machen haben sie sich dann
umgruppiert aber das war keine situation
wo sie ihre militärischen möglichkeiten
ausgereizt haben und ich mein normales
geht nicht darum dass ich mitleid mit
putin habe ich finde diesen krieg
verbrecherisch sowie jeden krieg der in
den letzten 20 30 jahren oder überhaupt
gegen krieg verbrecherisch finde also
das ist überhaupt nicht meine intention
die frage ist ja nur wie man damit
umgeht dass russland eine atommacht ist
und wie man verhindert dass aus diesen
krieg in der ukraine ein großer krieg in
ganz europa wird wo wir dann auch ein
drin einbezogen sind erwachsen und ist
er also wirklich auch atomare
eskalationspotenzial hat und das möchte
ich nicht und deswegen finde ich muss
man es wieder geben was ich angst wurde
weil doch auch eine falsche alternative
was heißt ergeben der verzicht auf eine
nato mitgliedschaft ist kein ergeben
sondern das wäre einer woche noch
möglich da wir uns wenn man wenn man im
ort ab gibt also ein sonderstatus heißt
ja noch nicht dass jetzt der don was
irgendwie zu russland wird im minsker
abkommen war auch ein sonderstab für den
donnerstag das hat er am anfang mit
aggression zb soll bereits der rubel
eingeführt werden da sonst eine
abstimmung geben also das ist eine lehre
oder was sie da verhandelt haben da war
glaube ich nicht davon die rede dass der
rubel eingeführte aber das aber wir
reden ja darüber was jetzt passiert und
da ist es so dass in diesen städten
bereits darüber gesprochen wird dass es
dann eine abstimmung über einen
möglichen anschluss geben soll
verhandelt wird russland klar da bloß
nichts falsch machen sagt schaffen
deswegen muss man verhandeln und da muss
man solche fragen auf den tisch legen
und muss man gucken dass man einen
kompromiss findet aber nochmal dem was
der presse zu entnehmen war war das was
dort verhandelt wurde mit russland
abgestimmt die hätten das gemacht
nachdem was man gelesen hat oder
zumindest war es ein weg zu einem
waffenstillstand wo nicht die russen
gesagt haben wir ziehen uns zurück
sondern die ukraine haben gesagt die
zugeständnisse die sind wieder die die
nebenbei vom tisch so und das finde ich
falsch und ich finde man hat dadurch den
krieg willkürlich verlängert und aktuell
finde ich das große problem dass man gar
nicht mehr versucht zu verhandelt man
versucht ist doch gar nicht ich mein
wenn es scheitert weil putin nicht
bereit verwandelt doch das stand ja das
stimmt einfach nicht ich habe wenige
tage nach butscher als es diese
kriegsverbrechen dort gab wo menschen
abgeschlachtet wurden auf den straßen
saß mir der präsident der ukraine
gegenüber und ich habe die frage
gestellt und habe gefragt als lenski
können sie angesichts dieser bilder in
butter wo so viele zivilisten
abgeschlachtet wurden noch mit putin an
einem tisch sitzen werden sie bereits zu
verhandeln und er hat gesagt natürlich
wäre ich bereit zu verhandeln aber
wladimir putin erkennt ja nicht mal
würde mir so lenski als dem präsidenten
der ukraine haben wir vielleicht ist das
format das erstmal delegation war
verhandeln sowie in istanbul gar nicht
so schlecht also wenn die zwei
miteinander verhandeln dann geht es ja
nur wieder darum dass jeder dort also
als der sieger rausgeht das ist aber
nicht ein sinnvoller eine sinnvolle
voraussetzung deswegen wenn es
verhandlungen gäbe wäre es schon
sinnvoll dass das erst mal so zu sagen
leute vertreter machen und meine sorge
ich finde wir als westliche staaten
haben auch eine verantwortung uns dafür
einzusetzen dass es wieder verhandlungen
gibt und nicht das zu tun was damals
passierte seelands hier unter druck zu
setzen dass er keine kompromisse sind
auch einmal gerne frau wage ich doch auf
ihrer ihre angst eingehen sie haben eben
schon angesprochen wenn das in der
ukraine die restliche welt damit in den
krieg reinzieht sie haben kürzlich
gesagt herr scholz ich will kein held
sein ich habe angst vor dem krieg
glauben sie dass es möglich wäre dass es
im bereich des möglichen liegt dass der
dritte weltkrieg ausbricht also ich
fürchte zumindest dass es
wahrscheinlicher ist als jemals seit dem
ende des kalten krieges und das muss
nicht mal ein plan sein also ich glaube
auch nicht dass putin morgen auf den
atom knopfdruck da ist auch viel
drohpotenzial usw aber wir liefern
waffen wir bilden ukrainische soldaten
aus was ist wenn russland zb eine
waffenlieferung eine panzer oder was
auch immer an greift bevor sie
ukrainisches territorium erreichen
schießen wir dann aus vollen rohren
zurück dann sind wir mit russland im
krieg und relativ sicher dass sagen
militärexperten ist wenn es einen krieg
zwischen dem laden zwischen der nato und
russland gibt dann wird dieser krieg
irgendwann nuklear eskalieren weil
russland konventionell keine chance
hätte in einem solchen krieg und das ist
eine unglaubliche gefahr und ich sehe
auch zum beispiel jetzt finnland wird in
die nato also finnland schweden werden
eintreten russland hat angedroht dass er
das sie dann kaliningrad aufrüsten das
heißt immer mehr militärpotenzial steht
sich gegenüber und auch im kalten krieg
war immer die angst dass mal ein
missverständnis also einfach ein
computerfehler weil die vorwarnzeiten so
kurz sind dazu führen kann dass eine auf
dem vermeintlichen gegenschlag knopf
drückt und es ist gar kein gegenschlag
und auch dann ist nokia europa also
sowas von verheert und und es werden
millionen menschen sterben also ich
finde das ganz gefährlich was aktuell
passiert und wir müssen aufpassen dass
wir uns nicht immer mehr in diesem krieg
einziehen lassen ich glaub angst ist
kein guter ratgeber bei der frage
wie man mit diesem krieg umgeht und ich
glaube man muss vor allem sich immer die
frage stellen was wäre die alternative
gehen wir mal durch wenn wir keine
waffen liefern wenn die usa keine waffen
liefern dann würde die ukraine diesen
krieg verlieren dann würde russland ganz
schnell wieder in kiew sein und dann
würden sehr viele butchers dort
entstehen und es ist so wenn wir uns das
anschauen und überlegen was die
russische armee in diesen dörfern in
diesen städten gemacht hat die
vergewaltigung
menschen zivilisten erschossen auf
grausamste weise getötet dann ist es
doch unsere aufgabe alles zu tun
wirklich alles zu tun dass das nicht
passiert
und dafür muss man den krieg beenden
also in kriegen ja natürlich an das
furchtbare schuldig muss man ganz dicht
am geschehen und deswegen muss man doch
alles daran setzen das wäre ja das
ergebnis auch eines waffenstillstands
natürlich dass die russischen truppen
abziehen also dann wird es auch keine
verbrechen mehr geben und wenn sie sagen
die sind dann morgen wieder in kiew sie
waren ja nicht in kiew auch ohne die
waffenlieferungen wahnsinnig in kiew
reisen travelhouse geil natürlich gern
auch schon sehr stark hochgerüstet
passen die führung der usa natürlich
wurde kiew mit westlichen waffen
verteidigt unter anderem auch mit
deutschen panzer abwehr
panzerabwehrraketen da gab es natürlich
westliche war wir haben ja damals noch
nichts geliefert das
klingt viel ist eine relativ moderate
rüstungsindustrie wir sind ja selber
rüstungsexporteur vor dem krieg gewesen
also es ist ja nicht so dass da ein ganz
ohne ausland aber es ist ein vollkommen
aber ist und auch
geheimdiensterkenntnisse zum beispiel
der usa die geteilt wurden mit den
ukrainern ohne westliche waffen das
sagen alle experten natürlich
die
ergebnisse waren wichtiger als die
waffen also die waren offensichtlich
wirklich wichtig weil sie haben ja
offensichtlich mit ihren aufklärungs
geheimdiensten tatsächlich auch dazu
geführt dass dann eben auch generelle
getroffen wurden usw also das hat ja
stattgefunden nur die frage ist was
wollen wir was bild deutschland was will
die nato was wollen die lässt westlichen
länder wollen wir dass wir jetzt einen
langen langen krieg dort in der ukraine
mit immer mehr waffen munition ihren und
nehmen dabei in kauf dass jeden tag
menschen sterben dass immer mehr
menschen sterben das auch je brutaler
unsere waffen sind desto brutaler die
kriegsführung von putin wird oder sagen
wir wir setzen alles daran
und ehrlich gesagt finde ich ist das
auch eine aufgabe der europäer nein
natürlich sehen also wenn herr beiden
sagt doch überall wir müssen uns auf
einen langen krieg einstellen rösler
will frei sein doch wir wollen mit
russland maximal schwächen das ist ein
anderes kriegsziel ich meine wir haben
das doch vorhin gehört
werden wird doch gesagt hat doch der
amerikanische verteidigungsminister
sagt aber es ist auch eine erfahrung die
russische armee und natürlich ist muss
unser ziel sein diese russische armee
zusammen mit der ukraine maximal zu
schwächen damit ist eine modische ist
doch die hat doch ein potenzial von ich
meine wenn die eine generalprobe machen
haben das ist ein so
bevölkerungsreichstes land und die haben
auch eine ganz starke rüstungsindustrie
die bauen selber wieder waffen und sie
bauen panzer sehen doch manchen reicht
die russische armee bereits jetzt ist
sie ist nicht modern also ausgestattet
aber dass sie immer wieder auch
militärisches gerät selber auch
herstellen kann auch in der ukraine
einsetzen kann ich meine die situation
ist doch seit dem märz seit damals die
fahndung geplatzt sind zu heute nicht
für die ukraine vorteilhafte also hinein
aus kiel fahren sie damals schon weg das
war das war schon aber sie sind ja
langsam im don was natürlich vorgerückt
und dem so würde ich gerne einmal herrn
richter noch mal um seine expertise
bitten und fragen wie hoch denn die
atomare gefahr ist
also es ist ja nett dass sie mich noch
an der diskussion beteiligen vielen dank
für
die atomare gefahr ist natürlich immer
dankbar wenn man tatsächlich von einem
szenario ausgeht in dem das bündnis und
russland sich in einem offenen krieg
befinden es ist ziel und auch aussage
klare aussage auch der bundesregierung
aber auch von beiden gewesen dass man
nicht kriegspartei werden wolle man kann
man sich auf einen rechtlichen
standpunkt stellen dass
der natürlich sagt man kann sich wenn
man angegriffen wird individuell und
kollektiv verteidigen
insofern wäre sogar eine militärische
beteiligung möglich aber das völkerrecht
ist das eine und die praxis und der
pragmatismus und die gefahren für die
sicherheit in europa sind das andere
natürlich müssen wir alles vermeiden was
in diese richtung der eskalation läuft
aber auch unterhalb dieser schwelle gibt
es natürlich eine andere art der
eskalation die liegt eher an der
ressourcen bildung natürlich ist
russland in der lage über mobilmachung
dennoch weitere ressourcen zu
mobilisieren
wir sollten auch den operativen gewinn
oder sie gefragt bzw in kiew jetzt nicht
so überbewerten dass wir das jetzt schon
zum sieg über die russische armee
erklären im donbass ist die russische
armee immer noch stabil und wir haben
dabei vielleicht auch übersehen und
gewertet dass die im süden immerhin es
geschafft haben einen landkorridor zu
bilden von der krim bis zum don was und
auch noch westlich mit einem finger in
richtung carlsson diese operation
scheint auch noch stabil zu sein das
heißt auch unterhalb der ebene an der
direkten kriegsbeteiligung von
bündnispartnern sehe ich die gefahr
einer weiteren eskalation durch die
mobilisierung von ressourcen das heißt
das ergibt sich dann eine
materialschlacht die auf der westlichen
seite natürlich durchaus gefüttert
werden kann aber man sollte hier was
dran die unterschätzen das heißt wir
kommen hier nicht raus aus dem zwang zu
verhandeln und leider ist es oft in
kriegen so dass die verhandlungs
elemente schon zu beginn des krieges
vorliegen und wir haben ja schon auf die
kompromissbereitschaft salans ist
verwiesen aber gestern habe ich gehört
dass der außenminister kollege das ziel
ins auge gefasst hat einer
gegenoffensive nicht nur im juni
generell sondern auch um die krim wieder
zu erobern und das sind natürlich escala
torische momente wo ich dann eher denke
dass die eskalation auf beiden seiten so
zunimmt dass die opfern hat habe ich
auch zu nehmen da beides weder die
eskalation in richtung kriegs ausweitung
noch diese art der materialschlacht in
unserem interesse sein kann glaube ich
schon wir müssen uns bemühen die ukraine
so zu unterstützen dass sie ihre
souveränität verteidigen kann aber wir
dürfen nicht jetzt kriegsziele es nicht
tricks während der parteien formulieren
die weit darüber hinausgehen und dann
wiederum eine skala tores potenzial
haben das heißt ich setze darauf dass
waffen liefern dazu führen dass die
souveränität verteidigt wird dann muss
aber auch der druck kommen tatsächlich
ernsthaft über diese elemente zu
verändern die wir bereits gesprochen
haben hier kann wir vielleicht noch mehr
tun aber natürlich wird auch unterhalb
der öffentlichkeit unterhalb der
oberfläche also da schon einiges
passieren um diesen kompromiss frieden
herbeizuführen ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob alle alliierte hier da wirklich von
einer von demselben gesangs blödsinn
über
waffenlieferungen und weitere sanktionen
ob die etwas bringen wie schädlich sie
sind sprechen wir jetzt nach einer
kurzen unterbrechung
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter krach
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren beiden für den 85 plätzen sind
meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht rüber jiechi jörges retten seit
august aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darin führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur
derart zu überlassen lasst den leuten
soll man spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu fügen
und sie sollen dem doch auch richtig
durch
das ist schon ein dass conti zum manko
vielleicht einmal kurz ein
doch das sind übliche anorak trainer
ausgestreckt
ich habe meinen beifahrer meine sache
immer bekommt er kümmert sich darum
niemand tut ist
man muss ja ganz knapp drüber sprechen
das ist einfach nicht fertig richtig wo
ist die ausgabe von journalismus einfach
die verlautbarung der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück bei 48 schön dass sie
dran geblieben sind und wir wollen jetzt
einmal reinhören in den bundestag was
heute mittag weil ich jetzt erst aber
was frau wagenknecht heute gesagt hat zu
den sanktionen
hätten sie nicht da ist die ganze
sanktionspolitik uns vielmehr als putin
schadet fehlt ihnen gar nicht auf dass
der euro seit februar immer mehr an wert
verliert während der rubel inzwischen
sogar höher steht als zu beginn des
krieges da muss man doch mal darüber
nachdenken warum das so ist russland
kann seine energie eben auch woanders
verkaufen denn der größte teil der welt
beteiligt sich eben nicht an ihren
sanktionen aber bei uns gehen bei
explodierenden energiekosten
wortwörtlich die lichter aus
bei uns gehen die lichter was paul wenn
du das hörst du blickst du auf die
sanktion ich bin da sehr fassungslos
über das was frau war eigentlich gesagt
hat wenn man gerade aus dem krieg in der
ukraine kommt und gesehen hat zu was die
russische armee im stande ist wie viele
menschen dort gestorben sind dann zu
sagen
die sanktionen müssen weg oder die
sanktionen bringen nichts
das halte ich für ein paar kilos
gegenüber der ukraine
ich meine wie können wir allen ernstes
weil das wäre dann sozusagen die
alternative
weiter mit putin mit einem
kriegsverbrecher mit einem geschäfte
machen
ja vielleicht weil es eben nicht schadet
wenn wir die geschäfte nicht machen also
wir sehen das noch aktuell wir haben
durch die zum beispiel jetzt ist ja die
bundesregierung auch für ein öl embargo
alleine die debatte darüber hat den
rubel preis er hat den ölpreis massiv in
die höhe getrieben
da rollt im kreml der rubel also dann
haben die mehreinnahmen als vorher und
dass man sich da wo ich darauf verwiesen
habe ich habe mir das vor kurzem selbst
bei angeguckt weil ich es gar nicht
fassen konnte also wie der rubel sich
erholen hat der ist ja eingebrochen als
der krieg begann und dann ist ein
stetiger aufstieg oder ist jetzt
deutlich stärker als vorher das heißt
wir schaden der russischen wirtschaft
oder den wwe schaden putin vor allem
auch gar nicht und wer hat stimmt nicht
wie den rubel und den kurs des rubel
naja ist initiator natürlich k tor aber
es geht natürlich auch um die
wirtschaftsstruktur und wenn man sich
dort die berichte anschaut dann schaden
die sanktionen natürlich sehr heftig der
russischen wirtschaft ja wir wissen darf
ich auch ein paar sachen unterscheiden
also ich habe gar nichts gegen sagen
schon im gegenteil die finde ich richtig
gegen oligarchen gegen leute aus putins
umfeld also wenn man da irgendwie eine
million hunderte millionenschwere jacht
beschlagnahmt und das geld irgendwann
für humanitäre unterstützung oder
wiederaufbau der ukraine verwendet
wunderbar also habe ich nichts
einzuwenden ich rede über die energie
embargos die sanktionen gegen kohle
gegen öl möglicherweise gegen gas und da
muss man ganz klar sagen es gibt auch
heute schon also selbst beim gas
russland hat pipelines nach china
russland hat zwei pipelines in die
türkei auch die türkei beteiligt sich
nicht an den sanktionen und ich meine
das irre was passieren wird ist doch
wenn wir zum beispiel sagen wir kaufen
kein gras mehr bei putin denn werden die
zwei pipelines zb in die türkei voll
ausgelastet die türkei wird dann dieses
gas weiterverkaufen am ende kommt das
gleiche größe schön gas wahrscheinlich
sogar bis hin zu uns weil wir haben ja
gar kein anderes nur dass es noch viel
viel teurer wird und am ende wenn sie
auch mehr pipelines bauen beim öl ist es
ja sogar noch leichter da brauchen sie
nur tanker die sie befüllen indien freut
sich wenn sie billige russische
rohstoffe bekommen china freut sich
viele länder sind gerne bereit billige
russische energieträger zu kaufen
während hier die preise durch die decke
gehen viele menschen wirklich aktuell
verzweifelt sind weil sie nicht mehr
wissen wie sie ihre rechnungen bezahlen
sollen ihre gasrechnung ihre
stromrechnung der sprit ist höllisch
teuer und das geht immer weiter durch
die decke obwohl wir damit ja nicht
ernsthaft wenn das ein instrument wäre
den krieg zu beenden jetzt sagen okay
wir müssen da jetzt durch dafür kriegen
wir aber dann auch innerhalb eines
überschaubaren zeitraums putin dazu dass
auf jeden fall dieser krieg beendet wird
okay da könnte man darüber reden aber
die sanktionen beenden den krieg nicht
also es gibt überhaupt keine chance
sondern wir werden so zu sagen wir
ziehen uns wir entziehen uns etwas was
unsere volkswirtschaft dringend braucht
nämlich preisgünstige in der
energieträger und daran hängt die
industrie in deutschland also das sind
100.000 industrie arbeitsplätze die
wegfallen
es werden ganze industrie branchen aus
deutschland wegziehen wenn hier die
energiekosten so hoch bleiben das ist
unser wohlstand das ist der wohlstand
von millionen menschen und ohne sinn und
verstand weil bei putin dann eben
woanders seine geschäfte macht was soll
das also ich verstehe es nicht also ich
das hat keine logik verrat nicht weil
die türkei oder china möglicherweise
bereit sind
weiteres nicht möglich oder sind dazu
bereit sind weiter geschäfte mit putins
zu machen kann es ja nicht im
umkehrschluss bedeuten dass wir deshalb
sagen okay andere machen es auch
deswegen müssen wir das jetzt auch
wieder tun und natürlich ist es bei den
sabbat nur uns manchmal das wissen also
dass das ist falsch vorwagen recht das
ist falsch natürlich wird der russischen
wirtschaft immens geschadet zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt durch diese sanktion das ist
fakt das zweite ist wenn wir darüber
nachdenken wie dieser krieg zu beenden
ist dann
sind die sanktionen natürlich in einem
in einem zeitraum zu betrachten ist
dauert bis sozusagen dieser schaden
größer wird und bis dann auch in der
russischen bevölkerung
möglicherweise das kann man nur hoffen
ein umdenken stattfindet das ist ja auch
der sinn dieser sanktionen um zu zeigen
um zu sagen das was ihr dort tut das
sind kriegsverbrechen das ist ein
angriffskrieg den in der ukraine führt
und das sind unsere sanktionen und das
ist natürlich auch unser moralischer
anspruch aber als erstmal glaube ich
sind wir uns einig dass russland keine
lupenreine demokratie ist also um das
man zynisch zu sagen also selbst wenn
die bevölkerung und wahrscheinlich sind
viele längst der meinung also ich meine
die umfragen ich weiß nicht wie ernst
man die nehmen kann ich denke schon dass
es russland viele menschen gibt die sich
gewünscht hätten dass es diesen krieg
nie gibt aber die fragt man doch nicht
und wenn die 1/10 schlechter geht wenn
die ärmer sind ja gut weil man sie
ernsthaft dass hat irgendeinen einfluss
auf die entscheidung im kreml und das
zweite ist eben natürlich wenn sie sagen
längerfristig jajeh längerfristig wir
planen desto besser kann putin unter
kann die russische wirtschaft sich
umstellen der zeitung eine fraktion
verhängt hätten wäre da nicht das
zeichen gewesen dass wir damit in
ordnung sind mit dem kriege der ukraine
naja ich muss ja mal sagen wenn wir die
gleichen maßstäbe überall anlegen gibt
es ganz viele länder mit denen wir nicht
verhandeln dürfen ich meine herbig hat
mit einem also bückling und kinderzahl
in katar ist der vaart der vorgesprochen
katar hat sich jahrelang an dem wirklich
furchtbaren und brutalen krieg im jemen
beteiligt gemeinsam mit saudi arabien
vereinigte arabische emirate frauen auch
immer noch auch immer noch dort krieg
führen sodann im jahr in katar gilt die
scharia also weil sie vorhin von
vergewaltigungen gesprochen haben was ja
wirklich ein ganz schlimmes verbrechen
ist wenn in katar eine frau vergewaltigt
wird dann kommt sie dafür ins gefängnis
die frau nicht der mann weil sie dann
eine ehebrecherin ist also ein land ist
das so da gehen wir jetzt hin und
betteln dass sie uns ihr teures
flüssiggas verkaufen weil wir das
billige putin gas nicht mehr wollen was
ist da logisch und wie gesagt putin kann
sein gas ja nicht nur nach china und in
die türkei verkaufen ganz lateinamerika
was nicht ganz fertig haben ich mache
die sanktion schlecht und sagen das
bringt nichts sie sagen dass waffen
nichts bringen und sie sagen sollen die
doch jetzt irgendwie verhandeln also ein
besonders ein das wahnsinnig naiv was
sie da sagen denn ein wir wissen doch
wie es jeden tag momentan im donbass
putins truppen versuchen weitere orte
einzelnen weitere städte einzunehmen und
die ukraine sich dort verteidigt er soll
sich ja auch verteidigen aber der krieg
ist da waren wir uns doch einig nicht so
gelaufen wie putin sich das vorgestellt
hat und deswegen kann man davon ausgehen
dass jetzt auch die russische führung
interesse an einer lösung hat die ihr
einen gesichtswahrenden herrn also warum
glauben sie das denn wenn wir uns
anschauen wie sich wie sich die
russische regierung verhalten hat ich
gebe ihnen recht die rede von wladimir
putin am neunten mal bei einem
gemeindehaus am 15 aber dennoch will er
ja diese besetzten gebiete mario pohl
die landverbindung
will im osten weitere gebiete die villa
sozusagen ja für sich beanspruchen und
das ist etwas was die garage am muss
akzeptieren nein natürlich nicht aber
darüber muss man verhandeln im kern geht
es in diesem krieg meines erachtens
nicht um territorial gewinne es geht um
geopolitik also das ist ja von anfang an
der streitpunkt gewesen russland wollte
nicht hinnehmen dass auch die ukraine
teil der nato wird dass sie teil der
amerikanischen einflusszone wird da kann
man jetzt sagen das ist nicht legitim
was geht es die russen an was in der
ukraine stattfindet andererseits sagen
die russen naja wenn die pakete waren im
jahr 2008 abgelehnt also ja und die usa
haben dieses diese entscheidung
eigentlich völlig virtuos ignoriert und
haben die ukraine de facto in die nato
strukturen in die militärischen
strukturen integriert ich meine wir
hatten im letzten jahr die situation
2000 us soldaten sind in der ukraine
stationiert gewesen
wir hatten
haben wir
weiter krieg ein wird aber eine
trainingsmission um sozusagen die
ukrainischen soldaten die waren auch ein
hermann ort zu bereichern ein indikator
auf sie gehört hatte und gesagt hätte
wir machen da gar nichts dann werden die
ukrainische soll daher vielleicht hätte
ich dann noch reinigt gericht auf einen
das haben sie doch selbst nicht vor wenn
wenn es stimmt also das ist eben der
dissens zwischen uns wenn es stimmt dass
es hier um geopolitik geht und nicht
darum dass hier einmal meint er muss
sein sein territorium ausweiten dann ist
es natürlich schon so dass der umstand
dass die ukraine immer stärker in die
nato integriert wurde das dort manöver
stattfanden dass das natürlich ein
wesentlicher grund dafür ist dass es den
krieg gab und ich erinnere auch daran
olaf scholz nach einem monat schritt
muss ja die workers deshalb weil
wladimir putin sein so 43 zurück
natürlich gesagt hat dass aus seiner
sicht die ukraine kann er ganz recht hat
hat das in einer wirren
nationalistischen rede gesagt aber
nochmal wenn
politiker ihr volk auf krieg einschwören
dann erzählen sie oft ziemlich
abenteuerliche sache und er hat es auch
nicht mal aufgeschrieben bevor diese
rede gehalten hatte ich einen hammer ich
finde wir sollten trotzdem die
langfristige den langfristigen konflikt
betrachten der langfristige kontrakte
ist ja nicht neu
in russland hat immer wieder gesagt wir
wollen nicht akzeptieren dass in der
ukraine quasi eine bastion der
amerikanisch nur ein vorreiter
anders aber doch seit jahren erzählt so
und ich meine wenn sie sagen das stimmt
alles nicht ja dann muss man es doch
wenigstens probieren gerade dann kann
man doch die probe aufs exempel machen
den putin einen solchen kompromiss
anbieten ok wenn er ihn ablehnt ja dann
wird der krieg weiter gehen aber man
sollte es versuchen und das problem ist
dass lenski sich von diesem kompromiss
verabschiedet hat also nicht putin hat
gesagt wir wollen den gestellen das als
fakt da sie stellen es als faktor dass
sie lenski jetzt an allem schuld sein
soll wenn das keine verhandlungen naja
salewski auch nicht alleine sondern wenn
ich der presse glauben darf und presse
wie guardian oder washington post würde
ich ernst nehmen als seriöse presse war
es so dass selen ski unter druck gesetzt
wurde diese option nicht mehr auf dem
tisch zu lassen sodass wurde dort
berichtet und es war zumindest zu
beobachten es gab verhandlungen es gab
auch in der deutschen presse übrigens
nach den planungen zunächst mal bericht
das war ganz aber freilich und auf ein
gerade wurde nicht mehr fahren denn auf
einmal war alles vorbei weil natürlich
dinge passiert sind wie in butter denn
das war ja sozusagen auch in einer phase
setzte noch einen grund mehr sagen denn
was steht da stand damals hat ja das hat
der see lenski auch gesagt aber er will
mit wladimir putin verhandeln und
natürlich gab es auch weiterhin kontakte
zwischen den ukrainern und den russen
die gab es und gewerbe sehen das anders
und realität an oder bietet man sie
nicht an aktuell bietet man sie nicht an
aktuell ist das vom tisch und damit hat
man natürlich kaum eine möglichkeit
wirklich einen verhandlungsfrieden zu
finden und ich glaube das ist der
schlüssel der sexualität bedeutet dass
sie am ende nur ein paar zehntausend
soldaten behalten dürfen in ihrem land
dann ist es auch nicht haben bedeutet
verknüpft und das ist natürlich die
angst der ukraine dass man wieder
irgendeinen bündnis schließt oder
abwesend am ende angekommen nach sechs
sekunden der sendung die sind jetzt ganz
schnell vorbei wenn sie mögen dann
schalten sie nächste woche dienstag
wieder einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]